dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly failures this is a
cone based ray tracing algorithm for
rendering photorealistic images of hair
and furry objects where the number of
hair strands is typically over a hundred
thousand okay wait what do these terms
mean exactly ray tracing means a bona
fide light simulation program where we
follow the path of many millions of
light rays between the light sources and
our camera this usually means that light
reflection and refraction Lens Blur and
D focus are taken into consideration
this feature is also referred to as
depth of field or DOF in short as you
can see in the video a fully ray trace
system like this for hair and first
leads to absolutely beautiful images
that you can see throughout this footage
so what about the cone based part
earlier we have an episode about voxel
cone tracing which is an absolutely
amazing technique to perform ray tracing
in real time it works by replacing these
infinitely thin light rays with thicker
cone shaped rays which reduces the
execution time of the algorithm
significantly at the cost of mostly a
minor sometimes even imperceptible
degradation in image quality since the
hair strands that we are trying to hit
with the Rays are extremely thin and
cone tracing make the Rays thicker
extending this concept to rendering
first without non-trivial extensions is
going to be a fruitless endeavor the
paper contains techniques to overcome
this issue and then efficient data
structure is proposed to store and find
the individual hair strands and the way
to intersect these cones with the fibers
the algorithm is also able to adapt the
cone sizes to the scene we have at hand
the previous techniques typically took
at least 20 to 30 minutes to render one
image and with this efficient solution
will be greeted by a photorealistic
image at least four to six times quicker
in less than five minutes while some
examples were completed in less than a
minute I cannot get tired of seeing
these tiny photorealistic furry animals
in Pixar movies and I am super happy to
see there is likely going to be
much more of these by the way if you're
subscribed to the channel please click
the little bells next to the
subscription icon to make sure you never
miss an episode also you can follow us
on Twitter for updates thanks for
watching and for your generous support
I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]